der böse macht ich laufe einfach mal her
hallo creeper noch einen hinsetzen kommt
dahin also was wir auch noch brauchen
ist auf jeden fall wolle bzw mehr
strings weil ich will pinkeln ich will
diese blöden nicht überspringen können
die tür kann ich mir schon mal machen
fällt mir grad auf schwere baum
gewachsen
wie viel braucht eine tür wie viel
braucht ihr 60
da sind skelette die hole ich mir gleich
ein paar sachen hier sichern
da kommt es nicht kommen
monsterjagd drei skelette oha übertreibt
man nicht
das trio war manno schnell dahin
schnell schnell schnell von crafter bot
bei skeleton uranerz ist meine ganze
erfahrung oder wecker wir werden ihn
nicht dazu kommen zum blödesten chart
mit dem zu machen
halle tommy hallo spinne
ach du scheiße mein ding ist kaputt
jedoch weg wird man weggeweht
ich hoffe wieder in zombie gibt erstmal
meine sachen hier eine schaufel und
sonde skelettteile hilfe
wir haben 5000 als bisher
ein volley machen das werde ich hier ja
dann hat das noch drei da sind noch zwei
so erst mal wieder ein bisschen muss man
schwer aus erschwert es kaputt gegangen
ein schwert brauche ich als christ on
the storm brauche ich noch fackeln
fackeln fackeln fackeln da brauchen wir
gar nicht lange fackeln hh bei uns kann
ich einfach mal wieder rein tun ich weiß
nicht ob es sie irgendwo hunde gibt
deswegen lasse ich das einfach mal
deswegen weiß ich kann ja schon die
dinge ins wachsen lassen die bäume hilfe
keine zombies
dann sieht sie auch ein bisschen schöner
als ich weiß gar nicht ob ich dir hinten
alle abfälle sehen wir den notfall dann
packe ich ein paar fackeln dran als sie
dass sie also ein bisschen schön dass
dann bekommt ihr wenigstens eine schöne
welt zum download und nicht so ein
tristes mit einander da sein keine
ahnung dass eine spinne das noch so
verriet bader gehe ich erst gar nicht
hin sehen auch schon mal schön aus oder
also ihr für mich ist das mittlerweile
fast gar keine cookies ist dann weg
cobblestone brauche ich fackeln wollte
ich machen stimmt stimmt genau
bei dem bogen setzling habe ich noch
feuchte ihnen hin wenn ein fach das
wollte ich machen
aja wenn ihr grab ein bisschen verwirrt
weil ich einfach immer verwirrt bin ich
glaube wir können uns irgendwann auch
seinen doppelten abbau der kamera bauen
hier weil dann packen wir da noch wasser
hin und dann geht das alles ganz schnell
aber dafür brauchen erstmal die infinite
water source so und ich möchte mich
jetzt erstmal bei allen noch ganz viel
spenden panschen damit wir demnächst
auch schlafen können schlafen können den
spannenden panschen so direkt zwei
machen könnt ihr zwei schwerter
jetzt haben aber keine spitzhacke mehr
gleich egal dass die sachen erst mal ich
glaube so viel ausrichten leuchten
möchte ich hier gar nicht im umkreis ich
packen immer so ein paar fakten aber ich
sehe dich nochmal auf dich aufmerksam
wird man vermissen ändern wären der
klotz sachen erkennt man sand der zwar
selten hier wo waren die blätter oben
ganz knapp das glück bei zwei
explosionen wow ich will doch ganz viel
tnt
man danke danke lieber creeper bist du
auch schon ganz lang machen oder sind 2
da kann ich aber ganz kurzem einen bogen
habe ich natürlich nicht mit wenn ihr
auch so klug das sonst schon wieder kann
man noch fleisch geben doch hat noch ein
gehört naja dann ist ein skelett aber
wir brauchen dingens hier spinnen später
muss ich bin ich es gab eine kumpanen
auf du was sagst du dazu
nach zwei oder mehr gut ich brauche
spinnen da sind zwei krippen ein skelett
skelette sind auch gut für pfeile und so
habe ich auch spinnen alter auf amazon
ganz ganz viele creeper und skelette
hinten auch noch herkommen aber keine
spinner wisse nur skelette creep
ansonsten schwachsinn den kein mensch
braucht vor allem steht der kripo noch
über mehr lesen zombieland ist noch ein
creeper skelett das spiel halo und
schickt sie zurück sind da ist eine
spinne bei ja da ganz hinten dennoch 2
nein nicht die sonne soll sie kriegen
ich soll sie kriegen oder zwei skelette
hier werde ich das sterben dass kann ich
euch jetzt schon sagen noch mal zwei
skelette das mich in ruhe das mich
darüber dass mich in ruhe
auch noch ganz viel monster ja cool ich
bin ich tot tot tot das spiel auf lasst
mich in ruhe schnell nach hause
zwei davon haben wir noch wir haben
allgemein stand eine wolle vorerst mal
bisschen regenerieren hier
ich bin gibt es für euch eigentlich
fische freue mich auch schon die
komplette zeit fertig geht als einfach
mal hin
ich brauche aber noch etwas zu essen ach
menno bist du was ich greife jetzt
einfach mal anleger sind level 6 real
hilfe
erst wirklich böse klappt der mark uns
nicht dann will ich sagen können ich
wieder ein bisschen cobblestone farmen
gehen können jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
machen
okay das war's dann bäume könnte ich
noch abfällen wir können uns dann ja
auch mal langsam an die aufgaben setzen
weil die grundvoraussetzung haben wir
langsam überfällig und zwar wir müssen
wir einfach ein bisschen rumlaufen dahin
ist noch eine spinne sich gerade ich
hoffe man dass die mich einfach ich
glaube dass übernimmt das skelett schon
das töten so joop dahin ist noch ein
skelett und ich hab ein herz und ich
werde jetzt sterben wenn ich daran
vorbei laufe schließlich ab los jay kay
kool herc liebe meine sachen gibt nur
eine sache der erfahrung
er hatte ich ein auge das war irgendwie
dann doch aus da hatte ich nicht egal
also jetzt kann ich noch mal kurz da
hinlaufen da waren nämlich eine menge
spinnen hat der rat auch mitbekommen und
danach wollten wir noch mal zu können
die höhle und schauen ob eine kiste war
bei wäre noch wasser brauchen auf den
berg da oben können wir auch noch mal
irgendwann drauf aber das würde ich
sagen mach einfach wenn wir gar nicht
mehr wissen wo wir hin sollen hier ist
echt keiner es keine so einfach nur
riesig fette wüste sonst ist ja echt nix
cras morgen nur sandkuhl und da unten
ist so unser unser ding vielleicht daher
hinter den berg die usa aber ich würde
sagen wir könnten ja eigentlich schon da
drauf gehen da oben ist stepstone
wir brauchen dafür eigentlich nicht
meine schaufel weil wir hier auf dem weg
ganz viel sand kriegen
du bist was wir bräuchten vielleicht
eine fackel dann können wir das das wäre
genial einfach mit der fackel alles
runter fallen lassen
das wer wird sich das machen wir jetzt
also ich denke ein paar leute von euch
kennen den trick ein paar auch wiederum
nicht
dann kann ich ja mal ein bisschen was
zeigen und zwar wenn man ganz viel sand
übereinander hat und man baut den
untersten ganz schnell oder sogar
fackeln an bord den untersten ganz ganz
schnell ab man setzt dann ganz ganz
schnell eine fackel hin
dann fällt der ganze sand auf diese
fackel drauf und platscht quasi so
zusammen es ist eigentlich ganz cool
wenn man ganz schnell sandfarben will
muss meine spitz kaputt gegangen
sand ist eigentlich immer gut können
direkt auch wieder gehen
ich hätte wir sterben wir werden gleich
an einem elendigen hungertod sterben
ich hoffe mal das lohnt sich da oben
oder darum ist einfach nur erde welche
ich meine wir haben genug erde das
einzige was ich brauche es eine infinite
water source also noch eine zweite
wasserquelle zweiten einmal wasser lasst
mich hoch so wartet die zeigt euch mal
den trick nicht viel da oben ist viel
das fällt jetzt alles schön runter als
auf die fackel nehmen ganz ganz viel und
können uns damit jetzt hier hoch bauen
eine ganz ganz ganz einfach ist das wird
darauf servern sehr häufig benutzt da
gibt's dann einfach nur so große flächen
aus sand da kam eine fackel hinstellen
und dann gehts da quasi schon runter bei
so kleinen sachen die hier bringt das
halt nicht viel bringen wir sie nur ein
bisschen
ich hoffe ich schon gesagt ich hoffe
einfach dass sich das lohnt das jetzt
setzt oben krabbeln für solche risiken
das ist viel zu hoch
plopp plopp plopp plopp plopp plopp
plopp plopp plopp
wir sind wir noch nicht wie hoch ist
denn das
manchmal platziert man dann auch die
dinge zu schnell und jetzt habe ich ein
kleines problem denn wenn ich den jetzt
abbauen
fällt er wieder sein darunter hätte ich
da drunter gestanden dann wäre ich
ziemlich blöd gewesen weil dann wenn das
auf mich drauf und ich wäre steckt und
das ist nicht so toll wenn ihr sand auf
den kopf kriegt oder erde oder irgendwie
sowas im echten leben dann erstickt man
und das wollen wir natürlich alle nicht
da wollt ihr das kommt darauf an was ihr
filmcharakter habt so sind jetzt oben
alter wir sind echt schon krass hoch
vielleicht können wir von hier auch
irgendwie die oase sehen oder so ja gott
da oben ist echt nur erde doch eine
kiste er ständig dachte schon toll auf
darstellt wird gleiche lesens pongau und
einen mushroom daher stellt diese auch
egal er da haben eigentlich auch genug
ist kann mich jetzt hier alle einsammeln
na ja ich nehme das einfach mal mit hier
auch noch das schild das er mit das
wichtigste
ich könnte jetzt mal so viele einfach
hier runter springen
aber ich möchte das noch mal ganz nah
da haben wir also einen eingang und das
sieht aus wegen sonne sondern vulkan
oder so sollen wir denn sonst noch so
alles ist schön dass sich ob die fallen
drin hat sonst sich wirklich gar nichts
aber da hinten da könnten wir nicht mal
hin dass bestimmt was das hängt mit der
story hier zusammen mit diesem hobby
dingsbums christel schüssel oder wie es
hieß aber manchmal kenne
ich komme ich jetzt hier wieder runter
mich einfach riesig und das kann ihr das
überhaupt die autos gesetzt was bis nach
unten
gut dann haben wir jetzt auf jeden fall
die tür die wir brauchen damit seine
farben zu machen also was man vorher da
kann ich gleich abhaken pilz fahren kann
ich gleich auch schon abhaken will zwar
muss aber dunkel sein und das ist wieder
blöd dass
ich glaube ich mach dir einfach eins
hoch bei 2 hochs bonn das schon monster
drinnen oder ich weiß es gar nicht ich
glaube ich mach dir mal zwei jahren
schaudern
weil das ich hatte das bett trauminsel
mit skate habe ich das eher aufgenommen
da war das so dass wir die pelzfarm
gemacht haben unter der erde haben die
zwei hoch gemacht und sind danach ein
monster transport und das war nicht ganz
so toll
das glaubt ihr uns auch bestimmt weil
dann war auf einmal seinen keeper drin
und wir waren halt beide gerade unten
gehen dass auch ein wollten artikels mit
dem auf einer putz konkreter an wir
waren beide tot und wäre dann erst mal
so fühlen ja natürlich eine kluge idee
von uns dass zwei hoch zu machen